aujourd'hui plus de 800 millions de
personnes souffrent de sous nutrition
dans le monde 9 millions d'individus en
meurent chaque année mais il ya de
l'espoir quand même un petit peu les
résultats d'un essai clinique sur la
malnutrition menée dans la province du
kassaï en république démocratique du
congo ces résultats indiquent une
nouvelle approche de la prise en charge
des enfants malnutris pourrait permettre
de lutter plus efficacement contre ce
fléau pour en parler nous sommes avec
julia siggers bonjour julien déjà un
petit point sur ce que c'est la
malnutrition
oui c'est important de revenir sur ce
terme la malnutrition parce que c'est un
terme qui est tout simplement méconnu
mais selon l' oms eh bien ça définit
autant les carences que les excès et les
déséquilibres dans l'apport énergétique
ou nutritionnelle d'une personne donc ça
veut dire que ça en blog englobe tant
elle la sous-nutrition que la
suralimentation la sous nutrition qui va
bien sûr engendrer un retard de
croissance une insuffisance pondérale ou
encore d amaigrissement oui la
suralimentation qui mène à l'obésité et
du cou à toutes les pathologies
associées comme par exemple les maladies
cardiaques le diabète ou encore certains
cancers mais dans les deux cas en fait
ça affaiblit considérablement le système
immunitaire des personnes et c'est pour
ça qu'on dit aujourd'hui que et bien
c'est la première cause de mauvaise
santé et de décès dans le monde tout
simplement parce que eh bien ça ça va
c'est autant les pays développés que les
pays en voie de développement qui sont
qui sont concernés
aujourd'hui on va pas parler de
surnutrition de mai de sous-alimentation
donc les chiffres sont alarmants julien
oui on avait fait beaucoup de progrès
les ong sur le terrain et fait beaucoup
de progrès dans les dernières années
justement pour lutter contre la sous
nutrition
mais à cause du coc vide et d'autres
facteurs d'ailleurs aujourd'hui vous
avez plus de 800 millions de personnes
vous l'avez dit qu'ils souffrent de sous
nutrition dans le monde vous avez 24
pays qui sont aujourd'hui considérés un
risque de glisser vers une situation
plus compliquée comme vous le voyez bien
ça concerne majoritairement
l'hémisphère sud notamment en afrique
notamment la la région du sahel ce sont
les femmes et les enfants qui sont les
plus affectés par ce fléau et il faut
faire une distinction en fait quand on
parle de sous nutrition vous avez d'une
dune par la malnutrition qu'on va
appeler aiguë et là ça va être tout de
suite dans l'immédiat ça va être lié à
une importante privation de nouri de
qualité mais ça m'a aussi lié à par
exemple des diarrhées ou alors du
paludisme et après vous avez ce qu'on
appelle la malnutrition chronique qui
est un peu différente ce qui est dans le
temps en fait vous avez du mal à vous
alimenter correctement et ça va donc
s'installer il ya plusieurs facteurs qui
mène à la sous-nutrition vous avez bien
sûr le changement climatique l'accès au
real eau potable bien sûr mais aussi la
pauvreté et les conflits évidemment on
pense au yémen en ce moment où il y à de
nombreux cas de de malnutrition aiguë
alors justement grand parle de la
malnutrition aiguë particulièrement ce
qui est très important c'est le
dépistage précoce et il y à ce constat
de du bureau des nations unies pour la
coordination des affaires humanitaires
ocha qui estimaient en 2019 que seuls 30
% des enfants qui souffraient de
malnutrition ou en tout cas de plus taux
de malnutrition aiguë et bien seuls 30 %
d'entre eux avaient accès à un soin et
c'est pour ça que l'association à lima
qui est une ong qui a travaillé sur le
terrain a décidé de développer un tout
nouveau protocole qu'ils auront testé
dans un essai clinique qui a d'ailleurs
fait ses preuves vous l'avais dit en rdc
je vous propose pour en parler de nous
tourner vers notre invité
alors excusez moi sont sont en jeu les
îles excusez moi mais dr rodrigues alita
nous responsable régional donc du
programme qui s'appelle optima pour
halima bonjour bienvenue merci d'être
avec nous
alors en quoi consiste cette nouvelle
approche que vous avez donc appelé
optima et comment est-ce qu'elle
simplifie les choses par rapport au
protocole que l'on appelle standard qui
a été mis en place et qui est utilisé
depuis de nombreuses années
merci déjà merci pour l'intérêt que vous
portez sur ce sujet pour le moins dans
la question d'abord rappelé le contexte
la projetant h&m une prise en charge
d'un grave ennui sion a été mise en
place suite à la grande crise
nutritionnelle au milieu des années 2000
et cette approche consiste à identifier
les enfants sont de la même vision
partout j'ai cliqué avec classifiés
habituellement selon le degré de
sévérité est allé soigner différemment
dans les programmes dont 10 fermes et
cette approche avec le temps a montré
ses limites alors la prospective pour
optimiser les achats de lamentations et
guide apporte trois éléments de
simplification importantes comme vous
l'avez souligné d'abord cette
publication dans la poche diagnostic
dans le sens qu'on utilise un seul outil
le périmètre brachial identifier les
autres mannequins au lieu de calcul plus
compliqué comme par exemple le bois
rameaux à la taille se payer cash et
aussi parce que en fait ce que rapporte
l'un des come here expliqué tom la
prostate et militaires du déchet tu as
probablement qu'un drame passionnel
différents et soutenir mutuellement des
agents sont aussi différentes ces
revendications dans le sens que nous
visons à la réduction du nombre
d'enfants atteints de malnutrition aiguë
qui ont besoin d'être hospitalisé vous
savez l'identification du traitement
précoce des enfants touchés par la vague
notion doit aboutir à une demande en
franc soyez un peu plus tôt de
précocement le processus et à le poser
sur la dénutrition est réduit à moins
n'apprend pas hospitalisés et par
ricochet moins de 17 ans que c'est comme
voir ce que
docteur on parle souvent du gâchis
alimentaire dans les pays
développés certains estiment que ce
problème de la sous nutrition ne devrait
plus exister en 2022 alors est-ce que
effectivement il y aurait une sur une
solution miracle que l'on n'adopte pas
ou est ce qu'il y a vraiment un manque
d'engagement de la part de la communauté
internationale ou est ce que l inverse
bien la situation est tout simplement
plus complexe que cela
oui l'explication est complexe et chez
alain nous observons chaque année le
long qu'en descendant prendre en
yvelines et je vous assure
la malnutrition est un véritable
problème de santé publique parce qu'on
les côtoie quotidiennement et ce qui est
pire que la région ait vus depuis un
mois ces canapés les conflits armés et
les conséquences des changements
climatiques ne faut pas noircir le
tableau alors pour lutter contre ce
fléau les réponses adressées de son
traitement médical conditionnelle elles
sont aussi politiques voyez il faut que
les gens quand les relations déjà
reparti sur les nouvelles approches plus
qui sont développés et qu'il y ait des
engagements au niveau de toutes les
nations ouais il faut dire aussi que
l'accès à une alimentation adéquate est
nécessaire mais pas suffisant il y à
aussi là c'est à nouveau aux soins de
santé donc dans tous les territoires le
développement durable sur la santé bien
être le climat rabais et aussi d'un
prince et vous même de la communauté
internationale il y a
plus d'engagements financiers dans le
monde force est de constater qu'ils
achètent pratiques autour de la
percussion et elle est maintenant
considérée comme une vie gens sont polis
par les bailleurs ou de citer le
coup on les a
merci docteur alita nous on n'a plus
beaucoup de temps mais merci infiniment
pour votre éclairage voilà je vous
invite également à aller sur le site
d'al hima parce qu'il ya d'autres sujets
de recherche qui sont extrêmement
intéressants pour essayer de lutter
contre ce fléau merci beaucoup julia
siggers pour cette chronique science
merci à vous